my name is Holly and this is a V and
thick today we will be reviewing both
the council's and carbon or cydia ideas
for the carpool south and cocoa in
sections of the red zone recover ISM
article is closest to the car through
north and cocoa eight sections of the
root zone so naturally more ideas and
into the plan for those two sections of
the red zone for the 350 for student
students aged 5 to 12 that participated
we ended up of nine hundred and five
flavors and total Pascal has been given
905 legs towards the regional public
plan they included about 700 ideas ones
175 likes and only a few concerns there
are some graphs that are related to UM
original recovery as you can see the
ideas on the first graph are a smack and
700 which is through the roof I can't
blame you because our school is full of
awesome ideas um the lights are average
lilo which leads room for brilliant
ideas the arm concerns are amazingly low
the graphic about different ideas that
school has given us the first one is
recreation which is quite high at 210
the second graph is reserved ecological
which is quite low at ten the next one
that's the highest yet it is the
businesses that are staggering 395 the
next one is a kind of embarrassing which
is social and that's at 0 the next the
next is non-recovery plain related which
is it 20 the rural which is it which is
next one that's on it five the last one
is housing which is at zero peary south
is a large area of our town that will be
a big impact on everyone by whatever
changes are made this regeneration area
of of Kuiper covers approximately 28
point to it it will be used for
residential and rural purposes in the
future highpoint ass girl had 350 for
students through the red zone recovery
plan model and provided feedback 905
flex the 905 flags leaves for likes
ideas and concerns most of the flags for
ideas but more likes we give them than
concerns which is good cowboy South has
a head approximately 300 flags for
mascot many of the art of our ideas for
business and recreational purposes in NF
and cowboy South cowboy staff will
create big impact on the pupils at our
school and whatever has finally decided
were meted to us our school had a number
of different ideas for the code for each
section of the red zone we have sort of
threat and picked out the most reliable
ideas 2% with the information provided
business based on what the issue said on
page 36 we don't think it as a wise idea
for there to be too many entertainment
buildings when your is at risk of floods
bad building land and the popular ideas
for entertainment I've generally based
on water parts ice skating rinks rock
climbing walls etc which would be a
waste as it will cost a fortune to
maintain and it would drain the budget
right down to the ground Oscar gave many
ideas and opinions about the new red
zone recovery plan we have all enjoyed
having a 3d model presented to us at us
go a couple of weeks ago thank you for
having us today and we hope to carry on
being part of the red zone discovery
plan for the future
you